Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Fate has ordained, but the men who went to the moon to explore in peace will stay on the moon to rest in peace. These brave men, Neil Armstrong and Edwin Aldrin, know that there is no hope for their recovery. But they also know that there is hope for mankind in their sacrifice. These two men are laying down their lives in mankind's most noble goal,
感谢您收听《历史余温》（The Rest Is History）。如需收听每周的额外剧集、享受无广告收听体验、抢先观看系列节目并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请前往 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。命运已定，但这些为了和平探索而前往月球的人们，将留在月球上安息。这些勇敢的人，尼尔·阿姆斯特朗和埃德温·奥尔德林，深知他们已无生还希望。但他们也知道，他们的牺牲为人类带来了希望。这两位勇士为了人类最崇高的目标献出了生命，
the search for truth and understanding. They will be mourned by their families and friends. They will be mourned by their nation. They will be mourned by the people of the world. They will be mourned by a Mother Earth that dared send two of her sons into the unknown. In ancient days, men looked at stars and saw their heroes in the constellations. In modern times, we do much the same, but our heroes are epic men of flesh and blood others will follow and surely find their way home man's search will not be denied but these men were the first
即对真理与认知的追求。他们的家人和朋友会哀悼他们。他们的国家会哀悼他们。全世界的人民会哀悼他们。孕育了他们、并敢于将两个儿子送入未知世界的地球母亲，也会哀悼他们。在古代，人们仰望星空，在星座中寻找英雄。在现代，我们依然如此，但我们的英雄是血肉之躯的史诗人物，其他人会追随他们的脚步，并一定会找到回家的路，人类的探索不会被阻挡，但这些人是先行者，
and they will remain the foremost in our hearts for every human being who looks up at the moon in the nights to come will know that there is some corner of another world that is forever mankind. So that, Dominic, was your hero, President Richard Nixon. Or rather, it was Richard Nixon as he would have been had the Apollo 11 mission gone wrong, had the Eagle not landed or had it been unable to take off, had Neil Armstrong and Buzz Aldrin been left stranded on the moon landings. That is the one that haunts me more than anything, because it really brings home the jeopardy, the incredible sense of danger that accompanied a mission that is now so much part of our imagination that we just take its success for granted, don't we? We completely do, Tom. Well, first of all, I will say, tremendous effort there. Thank you. I felt it was slightly wavery at times, but as we will discover, we won't give it away right away, but you were under tremendous pressure there. Thank you. I felt it was slightly wavery at times, but as we will discover,
他们将永远占据我们心中最重要的位置，因为未来每一个在夜晚仰望月球的人，都会知道在另一个世界的某个角落，永远属于人类。多米尼克，刚才那段话就是你的英雄，理查德·尼克松总统。或者更准确地说，那是如果阿波罗11号任务失败，如果“鹰号”没有着陆或无法起飞，如果尼尔·阿姆斯特朗和巴兹·奥尔德林被困在月球上，理查德·尼克松本会发表的演讲。那段演讲比任何事情都更让我心有余悸，因为它真正让人体会到了那种危机感，那种伴随着任务的难以置信的危险感，而如今这个任务已成为我们想象力的一部分，以至于我们认为它的成功是理所当然的，不是吗？确实如此，汤姆。好吧，首先我要说，你的表演非常精彩。谢谢。我觉得有时稍微有点颤抖，但正如我们稍后会发现的，我们不会马上剧透，但你当时承受了巨大的压力。谢谢。我觉得有时稍微有点颤抖，但正如我们稍后会发现的，
we won't give it away right away, but you were under tremendous pressure there. I was. I mean, because there is a Californian listening to this who has maybe dabbled a little bit in amateur dramatics himself. Bit of acting. In acting himself, exactly. So you did well under tremendous pressure. To be honest, Dominic, it was Richard Nixon talking about the search for truth and understanding that made me wobble. Of course, right. Yes. Yes.
我们不会马上剧透，但你当时承受了巨大的压力。确实。我是说，因为听众里有一位加州人，他自己可能也涉猎过业余戏剧。演过一点戏。他自己就在演戏，没错。所以你在巨大的压力下表现得很好。老实说，多米尼克，是理查德·尼克松谈论对真理和认知的追求那部分让我动摇了。当然，没错。是的。是的。
So it is an extraordinary thing, isn't it? When you think about the 20th century, it will of course be remembered in the long run for technology, for the world wars, for the terrible depths of man's inhumanity to man. But the one great shining light, I would say, is the sense that mankind was pushing the frontiers of technological exploration. And that that moment when man lands on the moon is the supreme symbol, I think, in the 20th century of the conquest of frontiers that would once have seemed absolutely impossible. And the sheer symbolism, don't you think, of that moment when Neil Armstrong steps onto the room. And you're absolutely right, I think, to emphasize the jeopardy,
所以这是一件非同寻常的事情，不是吗？当你想到20世纪时，从长远来看，它当然会因技术、世界大战以及人类对同类所犯下的可怕暴行而被铭记。但我认为，唯一一道耀眼的光芒，是人类正在推动技术探索前沿的意识。而人类登上月球的那一刻，我认为是20世纪征服那些曾经看似绝对不可能的前沿领域的最高象征。而且，当尼尔·阿姆斯特朗踏上月球的那一刻，那种纯粹的象征意义，你不觉得吗？而且我认为你强调危机感是非常正确的，
which is something we so often overlook. Now, you and I are too young, aren't we? I mean, I wasn't even born. Well, I'm not actually. You're too young to remember it, though. Yeah, I am definitely too young to remember it. But the good news is we have a guest today who does remember it. Now, Tom, we are a patriotic podcast. So it pains me, given our history with the French,
这是我们经常忽略的一点。现在，你我都太年轻了，不是吗？我是说，我当时还没出生。好吧，其实我不是。不过你确实太年轻了，不记得那件事了。是的，我确实太年轻了，不记得了。但好消息是，我们今天有一位记得那件事的嘉宾。现在，汤姆，我们是一个爱国播客。所以，考虑到我们与法国的历史，这让我感到痛苦，
this is our first guest who is a chevalier of the Légion d'honneur, would you believe? That we have it on the show. Yeah. on the positive side he is a fan of aston bella well it's not all bad two pretty deep black marks there tom but i'm prepared to overlook them because it is our first guest to have won not one but two academy awards for best actor in successive years it is of course top historian tom. Tom, welcome to the show. Thank you. And by the way, Tom Holland, a dead ringer as Richard Hanks. Thank you. Without a doubt.
这是我们节目中第一位获得法国荣誉军团骑士勋章的嘉宾，你敢相信吗？他来到了我们的节目。是的。从积极的一面来看，他是阿斯顿维拉队的球迷。好吧，也不全是坏事。汤姆，有两个相当严重的污点，但我准备忽略它们，因为这是我们第一位连续两年获得奥斯卡最佳男主角奖的嘉宾，他当然就是顶级历史学家汤姆。汤姆，欢迎来到节目。谢谢。顺便说一句，汤姆·汉克斯，简直就是理查德·尼克松的翻版。谢谢。毫无疑问。
Thank you. If you could say such things like, I am not a crook, and you won't have Dick Nixon to kick around anymore. Those were two of his other quotes. I'll feel like I'm sitting in the same room. Wow. You are too kind. That is charitable.
谢谢。如果你能说出像“我不是骗子”和“你们再也不能踢理查德·尼克松了”这样的话。那是他的另外两句名言。我会感觉自己就像坐在同一个房间里。哇。你太客气了。这真是宽宏大量。
That is so kind. That is so generous. That is a beautiful, it's odd to say, but a missed opportunity for some magnificent poeticizing in that speech that did not have to be given, in that it really does encapsulate the risk and the danger in the 50-50 one-shot only opportunity that Apollo 11 had and Apollo 12 had in order to land on the moon. And it only took, it took less than a year for the opposite to happen. On Apollo 13, that odd thing occurred, a bad valve, a misread test result, improperly interpreted reading, what have you, had it happened at any other point in the voyage to the moon, would have taken the lives of all three astronauts that were on board Apollo 11, Jim Lovell, Jack Swiker, and Fred Hayes.
你太客气了。你太慷慨了。那是一段美丽的——虽然这么说很奇怪——但那是一次错失的机会，没能在那个本不必发表的演讲中进行宏大的诗意表达，因为它确实概括了阿波罗11号和阿波罗12号为了登月所面临的风险和危险，那是一次只有一次机会的50/50赌博。而且仅仅过了一年，相反的情况就发生了。在阿波罗13号上，发生了那件奇怪的事情，一个坏掉的阀门，一个误读的测试结果，解读不当的读数，诸如此类，如果它发生在前往月球航程中的任何其他时刻，都会夺走阿波罗13号上所有三名宇航员的生命：吉姆·洛弗尔、杰克·斯威格特和弗雷德·海斯。
And Tom, that is a mission that is associated with you. I played, I was in the movie. I played Jim Lovell. I talked to all of those guys and did a deep, deep, deep dive into that other aspect of exploration was what happens when something goes wrong, terribly wrong. And what does it take in order to avoid the disaster that really would have defined, I think, the Apollo moon message, the American space race, and perhaps going to the moon. Just to ask, before we start looking at the history of how man ends up on the moon, what's
汤姆，那是一个与你相关的任务。我演过，我拍过那部电影。我扮演了吉姆·洛弗尔。我与所有那些人交谈过，并深入、深入、深入地研究了探索的另一个方面，那就是当事情出错，极其严重地出错时会发生什么。为了避免那场本会定义阿波罗登月信息、美国太空竞赛，甚至也许是登月本身意义的灾难，需要付出什么？只是想问一下，在我们开始研究人类最终如何登上月球的历史之前，你对它有什么
your kind of personal sense of it? It goes back to childhood, doesn't it? You were kind of playing games in swimming pools and things. Yeah. I'm 67 years old. I was born in 1956 and my school days dovetailed perfectly with the story of the decade. And as Dominic said, really of the 20th century, we were going to go to the moon. Human beings were going to walk on the moon as early as 1962. The question was when and who and how fast and which nation? Would it be the Soviet Union, who seemed to be light years ahead of us in their secrecy
个人的感受吗？这要追溯到童年，对吧？你当时在游泳池里玩游戏之类的。是的。我今年67岁。我出生于1956年，我的学生时代与那个十年的故事完美契合。正如多米尼克所说，确实是20世纪的故事，我们当时要登上月球。人类早在1962年就要在月球上行走了。问题是何时、由谁、多快以及哪个国家？会是苏联吗？他们在保密方面似乎领先我们好几年光年，
and in their accomplishments? Or would it be the very open and public and very expensive American space program? So from John Glenn or actually Alan Shepard in the early 1960s, I was in second, third, fourth, fifth, sixth grade. So I was 13 in July of 1969. And the only thing I was paying attention to outside of maybe some girls was the run-up to landing on the moon, which began really in earnest in the, I think, in the zeitgeist of Vox Populi starting in 1968 when Apollo 8 went to the moon and broadcast live from lunar orbit on television. And we saw that very particular vision of ourselves on the planet Earth in the distance in black and white.
在他们的成就方面也是如此？还是会是那个非常公开、透明且极其昂贵的美国太空计划？所以从约翰·格伦，或者实际上是1960年代初的艾伦·谢泼德开始，我当时在读二、三、四、五、六年级。所以1969年7月我13岁。除了可能关注一些女孩之外，我唯一关注的就是登月的倒计时，这在1968年阿波罗8号前往月球并在电视上从月球轨道进行直播时，真正开始在公众舆论中形成。我们看到了那个非常独特的景象：我们在远处的地球上，以黑白影像呈现。
But yet there we were. But seeing it on television, I was sitting in my mom's house in Red Bluff, California, thinking that history just cracked wide open. Something had happened that had never happened before. And so now it was just we had to complete the task. And when would that happen there were two more missions that when tested equipment and one flew to the moon again apollo 10 they did not land and it wasn't until that july where it was going to happen and it was a countdown it was it was a every day that ticked by every week, every headline was sort of like written.
但我们确实在那里。但在电视上看到它，我当时坐在加州雷德布拉夫我妈妈的房子里，心想历史刚刚被彻底打开了。发生了一件以前从未发生过的事情。所以现在我们只需要完成任务。什么时候会发生呢？还有两次任务，一次测试了设备，一次再次飞往月球，阿波罗10号，他们没有着陆，直到那个七月，它才会发生，这是一个倒计时，每一天过去，每一周，每一个头条新闻都像是被写就的。
All of the disciplines that I was studying, certainly it was current events, you know, the news of the day. But it was also science. It was also physics. Lift plus thrust is equal to load plus drag. It was engineering. It was mathematics of how do you build these rockets and how do you put three guys into it and how do you, what does it take in order to build something that can land on the moon?
我学习的所有学科，当然包括时事，你知道，当天的头条新闻。但它也包括科学。它也包括物理学。升力加推力等于载荷加阻力。它是工程学。它是关于如何制造这些火箭，如何把三个人放进去，以及如何，为了制造出能登上月球的东西需要什么，这些东西的数学原理。
It was science and technology because they had amazing computers that would help divine, you know, how to get there. Computers in the primitive sense. Your average calculator that you get for free on one of your apps on your phone now has more memory than everything that had on Apollo. And then there was also a degree of artistry to it, because I can't tell you enough of how much the combined presence of 2001 of Space Odyssey, the motion picture, as well as the poetry of Archibald MacLeish and the ongoing science fiction writing of anybody from Robert Heinlein to Arthur C. Clarke, this was all enmeshed in this world of before we land on the moon. I was very cognizant of that great, I overused the imagery of Rubicon that was crossed by
它是科学和技术，因为他们有惊人的计算机来帮助推算，你知道，如何到达那里。原始意义上的计算机。你现在手机上任何一个免费应用程序里的计算器，其内存都比阿波罗号上所有的设备加起来还要多。然后还有一种艺术性，因为我无法充分表达电影《2001太空漫游》的共同存在，以及阿奇博尔德·麦克利什的诗歌，还有从罗伯特·海因莱因到阿瑟·克拉克等人的持续科幻写作，在我们要登上月球之前，这一切都交织在这个世界里。我非常清楚那个伟大的——我过度使用了卢比孔河的意象——被
humankind on one side of the lunar river one day. And then the next day we had crossed over to the other side. All of humankind now were spacefaring, planetary visiting. And Tom, can I ask you, so you said you were born in 1956. Obviously, the following year, I think it is, is the year that the Russians launched Sputnik, which was a great shock for Eisenhower's America. How much were you growing is, is the year that the Russians launched Sputnik, which was a great shock for Eisenhower's America. How much were you growing up conscious of the fact that the space race was being driven by that kind of Cold War competition with an ideological adversary? Or was that not really on ordinary people's radar, would you say? No, it was us versus them. Turns out the threat
人类跨越了，有一天在月球河的一边。第二天我们就跨到了另一边。全人类现在都是太空旅行者，行星访问者。汤姆，我可以问你吗？你说你出生于1956年。显然，第二年，我想是苏联发射斯普特尼克卫星的那一年，这对艾森豪威尔的美国来说是一个巨大的冲击。你在成长过程中，对太空竞赛是由那种与意识形态对手的冷战竞争所驱动的事实有多大的意识？还是说这在普通人的雷达上并不明显？不，那是我们与他们的对抗。事实证明，斯普特尼克的威胁
of Sputnik was really just they'd been able to do it. Everybody was like, oh, now they can drop rockets on us. No, no, they couldn't. Sputnik was essentially a grapefruit-sized ball that was going beat, beat, beat. But the fact that they were able to do it in the first place was what kind of kicked America's ass for a while. How come they can do it when we can't? Then, of course, Yuri Gagarin goes up and it orbits the moon. And it seemed as though the Russians were building spaceships when Americas were kind of like sending up versions of toasters to see if they could work in outer space instead.
实际上只是他们能够做到这一点。每个人都觉得，哦，现在他们可以向我们投掷火箭了。不，不，他们做不到。斯普特尼克本质上是一个葡萄柚大小的球，发出哔、哔、哔的声音。但他们能够做到这一点的事实，在一段时间内确实让美国感到震惊。为什么他们能做到而我们不能？然后，当然，尤里·加加林上天了，绕月飞行。看起来好像俄罗斯人在制造宇宙飞船，而美国人却在发射某种烤面包机，看看它们是否能在外太空工作。
But it was. It was a competition, pure and simple, us versus them. And it was always in the perspective of they're beating us. We are losing. We're in second place because it was so secretive. Yeah, of course. Because Khrushchev kind of openly gloats, doesn't he, when he congratulates Gagarin and he kind of saying, let the capitalists catch up with us. They'll never beat us. And then of course, John F. Kennedy picks up the gauntlet. And since you were thrilled by my first impression of an American president, let me- So you asked for this, Tom. You opened the door to this. All right. Let's hear it. So this is September the 12th, 1962, and JFK gives a speech at Rice
但确实如此。这是一场竞争，纯粹而简单，我们与他们。而且它总是处于“他们正在打败我们”的视角。我们正在输。我们排在第二位，因为它是如此保密。是的，当然。因为赫鲁晓夫在祝贺加加林时公开幸灾乐祸，不是吗？他说，让资本家赶上我们吧。他们永远打不败我们。然后当然，约翰·F·肯尼迪接过了挑战。既然你对我的第一段美国总统模仿感到兴奋，让我——所以是你要求的，汤姆。你打开了这扇门。好吧。让我们听听。所以这是1962年9月12日，JFK在休斯顿的莱斯大学发表了演讲，
University in Houston, where of course, you know, mission control is and all that kind of thing, to 40,000 people. And he commits the United States to landing a man on the moon by the end of the decade. So he is providing a kind of a deadline. But why some say the moon, why choose this as our goal? And they may well ask why to climb the highest mountain? Why 35 years ago, fly the Atlantic? Why does Rice play Texas? We choose to go to the moon. We choose to go to the moon in this decade and do the other things not because they are easy, but because they are hard.
当然，你知道，任务控制中心就在那里，诸如此类，面对4万人。他承诺美国将在十年结束前将人类送上月球。所以他提供了一个截止日期。但为什么有人说月球，为什么要选择这个作为我们的目标？他们很可能会问，为什么要攀登最高的山峰？为什么35年前要飞越大西洋？为什么莱斯大学要和德克萨斯大学比赛？我们选择去月球。我们选择在这个十年内去月球，并做其他事情，不是因为它们容易，而是因为它们困难。
What do you think of that? So what people who are listening to this can't see is that actually Tom Hanks is in tears and horror at the destruction of an American icon. I mean, it's such a stirring speech. And I hope that I haven't completely destroyed any sense of the drama of it with that.
你觉得怎么样？所以听众看不到的是，汤姆·汉克斯实际上正因美国偶像的毁灭而泪流满面，感到恐惧。我是说，这是一场多么激动人心的演讲。我希望我没有用那种方式完全破坏它的戏剧感。
But it is. You can't screw up that text. You know, the words live. Right. Even the worst actor, you're saying. But it's an amazing commitment because failure in that mission will be so public. It's about as bold a statement as was ever to be made, I think, by any politician. Yeah. Now, later on in the famous speech to Congress, he says, I believe that we should dedicate
但确实如此。你不能搞砸那段文字。你知道，这些话是有生命力的。对吧。即使是最差的演员，你是这么说的。但这是一种惊人的承诺，因为任务失败将是如此公开。我认为这是任何政治家所能做出的最大胆的声明。是的。现在，后来在著名的国会演讲中，他说，我相信我们应该致力于
ourselves before this decade is out of sending a man onto the moon and returning him safely to the earth. Between that and what he said in the stadium at Rice University, and that, why does Rice play Texas? That was a great ad lib that he put in there for the local crowd. It really does state something much more than a political will, but sort of like the purpose and definition of humankind. Why would we try something like that? You can take that into account by why go across those mountains in primitive man, when all you can do is walk? Why go from here to there when it's on the other side of that body of water? Why do anything that was going to risk your life, cost a lot of money, maybe have absolutely no value at the end of the day. Why go off and
在这个十年结束之前，将一个人送上月球并让他安全返回地球。在那之间，以及他在莱斯大学体育场所说的，还有那个，“为什么莱斯大学要和德克萨斯大学比赛？”那是他为当地观众即兴发挥的精彩片段。它确实表达了不仅仅是政治意愿，而是某种人类的目的和定义。我们为什么要尝试这样的事情？你可以考虑到这一点，为什么原始人类要翻越那些山脉，而他们所能做的只是行走？为什么当它在水体的那一边时，要从这里走到那里？为什么要去做任何会冒生命危险、花费大量金钱、甚至在一天结束时可能毫无价值的事情？为什么要离开并
explore or try anything new? Because it is the human condition, not because it is easy, but because it is hard. He goes on and speaks about the test that is going to make of all of ourselves, of the people that are involved in that. They're going to have to just figure things out with no guarantee of success. In fact, a 50-50 chance of absolute public failure. And here's the thing that I think comes down to what backed up his ability to say such a thing, is there's a ton of people that want to do exactly that, that don't view themselves as being fully alive without trying the impossible, without attempting to figure out what has never been attempted. It is part of the human condition for some people to leave the
探索或尝试任何新事物？因为这是人类的状况，不是因为它容易，而是因为它困难。他继续谈论这将对我们所有人，对参与其中的人们进行的考验。他们将不得不弄清楚事情，而没有任何成功的保证。事实上，有50/50的绝对公开失败的几率。我认为这归结为他能够说出这样的话的原因是，有很多人想做完全相同的事情，他们认为如果不尝试不可能的事情，不尝试弄清楚从未尝试过的事情，就不算完全活着。对于某些人来说，离开
campfire and go outside the cave and see what's on the other side of the valley. And in this case, I mean, my God, I mean, here we have been looking up at this thing that has been above us in different shapes and forms more or less every single night of our existence. And depending on when we get up at night, sometimes the moon is there shining down on us. Sometimes it's just barely showing up. And it is this huge, big, circular, crescent, gibbous-faced source of light and perspective that can really, with only a few minutes of pondering, produce nothing but questions. What's up there? Can I go there?
营火，走出洞穴，看看山谷另一边有什么，是人类状况的一部分。在这种情况下，我的天哪，我们一直仰望着这个东西，它以不同的形状和形式，或多或少地出现在我们存在的每一个夜晚。根据我们晚上起床的时间，有时月球在那里照耀着我们。有时它几乎看不见。它是这个巨大的、圆形的、新月形的、凸月形的、光和视角的源泉，只需思考几分钟，就能产生无数的问题。上面有什么？我能去那里吗？
Why is it there? How did it get there? What does it mean? I mean, what does the moon mean? How does it affect us? I mean, I think it's interesting that crazy people were often called lunatics. Of course. Yeah. You went to a lunatic asylum. I've spoken to people in the psychiatric industry. They said,
它为什么在那里？它是怎么到那里的？它意味着什么？我是说，月球意味着什么？它如何影响我们？我是说，我觉得很有趣的是，疯子经常被称为“lunatics”（源自月球）。当然。是的。你去了疯人院。我与精神病学行业的人交谈过。他们说，
hey, what's the deal with the full moon? Does it really make people go crazy? And they said, why do you think they called them lunatics? Because even periodically that moon comes out and we all get a little bit hairy. We all turn into some version of, of werewolves. Yeah. And it's as certain as the tides being pulled,
嘿，满月是怎么回事？它真的让人发疯吗？他们说，你以为他们为什么叫他们“lunatics”？因为即使周期性地，那个月亮出来，我们都会变得有点毛茸茸的。我们都会变成某种版本的狼人。是的。而且它和潮汐被拉动一样确定，
you know, on bodies of water. So there's this thing that exists up there for some kind of reason. And as John F. Kennedy says, you know, we choose to go to the moon and do the other things, not because they're easy, but because they are hard. They're going to be a test of ourselves and why we're here on the planet Earth in the first place. Now, it's not far, I don't think, in order to take that and say, well, why try to figure
你知道，在水体上。所以那个东西出于某种原因存在于那里。正如约翰·F·肯尼迪所说，你知道，我们选择去月球并做其他事情，不是因为它们容易，而是因为它们困难。它们将是对我们自己以及我们为什么首先出现在地球上的考验。现在，我认为，采取这种说法并说，好吧，为什么要尝试弄清楚
out what bacteria is? Why not try to conquer viruses? Why not try to do any of the other things? Because they're not going to be easy. They are going to be hard. But at the same time, it's a problem that we are a problem-solving race. We like these mysteries and tasks. So you said something interesting there about Kennedy's pledge, his vigor, his optimism, tapping something in the human spirit. But now that you look back, do you think that the 60s, I mean, Kennedy obviously talked about the new frontier and all that kind of thing. Do you think that the 60s, that that was a peculiar moment? The kind of technological optimism, the can-do spirit, obviously the economy is doing really well you know the united states is really keen to flex its muscles i guess you know i'm not talking about militarily although there is a military dimension to it but you know there's a real sense of dynamism there the new whole new frontier thing conquering frontiers they're obviously now from the perspective of
什么是细菌？为什么不尝试征服病毒？为什么不尝试做任何其他事情？因为它们不会容易。它们会很困难。但与此同时，这是一个问题，我们是一个解决问题的种族。我们喜欢这些谜团和任务。所以你刚才关于肯尼迪的承诺、他的活力、他的乐观精神，触动了人类精神中的某些东西，说了一些有趣的话。但现在你回过头来看，你认为60年代——我是说，肯尼迪显然谈到了新边疆等等——你认为60年代是一个特殊的时刻吗？那种技术乐观主义，那种“能做”的精神，显然经济表现非常好，你知道，美国真的热衷于展示其实力，我想你知道，我不是在谈论军事方面，尽管它有一个军事维度，但你知道，那里有一种真正的活力感，全新的边疆，征服边疆，显然现在从
the 2020s we kind of don't have that to the same degree, do we? We're much more pessimistic, we're much more introverted. But do you think there was something unique about that spirit? So that climate in which you were growing up of kind of can-do, vigor, dynamism, all of that kind of thing? Without a doubt, the 1960s were this time where the newness of so much of our technological abilities as human beings was probably on display in a much more vigorous kind of way. I'm going to say somewhere between the advent of television through to the 1970s, maybe, when we could have the VHS machine and record everything. Suddenly, all this stuff was possible that had been the stuff of science fiction for generation upon generation. Even my dad, my parents could only get across the country really at the speed of a railroad.
2020年代的角度来看，我们没有达到同样的程度，对吧？我们更悲观，我们更内向。但你认为那种精神有什么独特之处吗？那种你成长过程中的那种“能做”、活力、动态的气候，所有这些东西？毫无疑问，1960年代是一个时代，作为人类，我们许多技术能力的崭新程度可能以一种更加充满活力的方式展现出来。我想说，从电视的出现到1970年代，也许当我们有了录像机并可以记录一切的时候。突然之间，所有这些曾经是几代人科幻小说素材的东西都变得可能了。即使是我爸爸，我的父母也只能以铁路的速度穿越全国。
And if they were going to make a telephone call, your voice had to get there along whatever electrons could fit onto a copper wire. And all of those barriers disappeared in the 1960s. Just communications in general went nuts. Yeah. And also in our own individual lives, it was an incredibly important invention, and it came about widely in the 1960s,
如果他们要打一个电话，你的声音必须沿着能装进铜线的任何电子信号到达那里。而所有这些障碍在1960年代都消失了。通信总体上变得疯狂。是的。而且在我们个人的生活中，这是一个极其重要的发明，并且在1960年代广泛出现，
was air conditioning. Because suddenly you could live in parts of the world that were inhospitable. Well, like Houston, right? Yeah. I mean, that's why it can be done in Houston. Because suddenly you could live in parts of the world that were inhospitable. Well, like Houston. Yeah. I mean, that's why it can be done in Houston. Houston's a swamp, for goodness sake.
那就是空调。因为突然之间，你可以住在世界上不适宜居住的地方。嗯，像休斯顿，对吧？是的。我是说，这就是为什么它可以在休斯顿完成。因为突然之间，你可以住在世界上不适宜居住的地方。嗯，像休斯顿。是的。我是说，这就是为什么它可以在休斯顿完成。休斯顿是个沼泽，看在上帝的份上。
It's a murky, humid swamp with bugs and spiders the size of your head. Yeah. And air conditioning comes along. And suddenly we are able to live our daily lives in this type of comfort and ease for the first time in all of human history. So along with that, I think, stirred this catalyst of, well, what else is possible? What else can we do? What else is fun? What else is going to be entertaining?
那是一个阴暗、潮湿的沼泽，有和你头一样大的虫子和蜘蛛。是的。空调出现了。突然之间，我们能够在整个人类历史上第一次在这种舒适和轻松的环境中过我们的日常生活。所以伴随着这一点，我认为，激发了这种催化剂，好吧，还有什么是可能的？我们还能做什么？还有什么是好玩的？还有什么是会让人娱乐的？
And what else can we do at nighttime when we're home done with our jobs? But also then, what else is going to be able to move us from here and there? And what else is going to be technologically imaginatively possible? It seemed there for a while that if you could imagine it, you could make it happen in the 1960s. That has just sped so fast that now we don't even think twice about all the things that are possible. And Tom, I should mention, I mean, this is a thought that was, it struck me very, very powerfully when I went to a show that you narrate, Moonwalkers, in King's Cross here in London, where we are, which is on at the moment, it's on, I think, till the 13th of October, 2024. And in that, you narrate the story of all the various Apollo missions. And one of the things that leaps out from that is how short the distance of time is
当我们下班回家在晚上时，我们还能做什么？但随后，还有什么能够把我们从这里移动到那里？还有什么是技术上、想象力上可能的？在那段时间里，似乎如果你能想象它，你就能在1960年代让它发生。那已经加速得太快了，以至于现在我们甚至不会对所有可能的事情三思而后行。汤姆，我应该提到，我是说，这是一个想法，当我去看你在伦敦国王十字车站解说的《月球漫步者》（Moonwalkers）展览时，它非常非常有力地打动了我，我们现在就在那里，它目前正在展出，我想直到2024年10月13日。在那个展览中，你讲述了所有各种阿波罗任务的故事。其中一件事跳出来的是，时间距离是多么短
between utter disaster and utter triumph. So Apollo 1, I mean, three astronauts die horribly burnt to death in their tin can, as David Bowie would put it. And they weren't even meant to fly. They were just doing tests on the ground. And something went so hideously wrong that they were incinerated to death and they couldn't even open the door to the space capsule. Because that seems a terror. I mean, Apollo 1, they die so horribly. The technology seems dodgy. And yet the speed with which the missions are being sent up. So we
在彻底的灾难和彻底的胜利之间。所以阿波罗1号，我是说，三名宇航员在他们的“锡罐”里被活活烧死，正如大卫·鲍伊所说的那样。他们甚至没打算飞行。他们只是在地面上做测试。有些事情变得如此可怕地错误，以至于他们被焚烧致死，他们甚至无法打开太空舱的门。因为那看起来是一种恐怖。我是说，阿波罗1号，他们死得太惨了。技术看起来很不可靠。然而任务发射的速度却很快。所以我们
already talked about Apollo 8 with Moonrise and Jim Lovell up there and everything. And then Apollo 10, dress rehearsal for the Apollo 11 lunar landing, which is called Snoopy, isn't it? The one that goes down. Well, yeah, but okay. Can we take a moment just to examine Apollo 10? Sure. Yeah.
已经谈到了阿波罗8号的“地出”和吉姆·洛弗尔在上面以及所有的一切。然后是阿波罗10号，阿波罗11号登月的彩排，叫“史努比”，对吧？那个下去的。嗯，是的，但是好吧。我们能花点时间检查一下阿波罗10号吗？当然。是的。
Well, Charlie Brown and Snoopy was a command module in the lunar module. Apollo 8 had gone around the moon and at christmas with three guys in it it was just them just to see if the math worked that paulo 8 was kind of like if we can throw this hammer far enough hard enough it will go around the moon and come back right and they did and i'll tell you this little side story charles lindbergh visited the crew of of Apollo 8 just before they were about to launch. And they said to him, you know, are you going to come back in July for the Apollo 11? Because that'll really be history because they're going to land on the moon.
好吧，查理·布朗和史努比是指令舱和登月舱。阿波罗8号绕月飞行，在圣诞节有三个人在里面，只是他们，只是为了看看数学是否有效，那阿波罗8号有点像，如果我们能把这个锤子扔得足够远、足够用力，它就会绕过月球回来，对吧？他们做到了，我告诉你这个小插曲，查尔斯·林德伯格在阿波罗8号机组人员即将发射前拜访了他们。他们对他说，你知道，你会回来参加7月份的阿波罗11号吗？因为那将真正成为历史，因为他们要登上月球。
And Charles Lindbergh said, no, you guys are making the most important flight in humankind. You guys are leaving the gravitational pull of the planet earth. That's never been done before. If you guys can do that, all the rest of this stuff is nuts and bolts. How about that? Yeah. So then let's take Apollo 10, Thomas Stafford, who is the commander and Gene Cernan.
查尔斯·林德伯格说，不，你们正在进行人类最重要的飞行。你们正在离开地球的引力。这以前从未做过。如果你们能做到这一点，所有剩下的这些东西都是螺母和螺栓。怎么样？是的。那么让我们看看阿波罗10号，托马斯·斯塔福德，他是指挥官，还有吉恩·塞尔南。
Gene Cernan is in Snoopy, the lunar module that cannot land on the moon, fly just a few dozen miles above its surface and willingly give up on the idea of landing and coming back home? I mean, you are so close and yet you're not allowed to park and go into Disneyland. You can only drive by and look at it. Is that why they called it Charlie Brown? They never got there. No, actually, the reason they called it Charlie Brown, because it was the first time they were going to have two different spacecraft that they had to talk to individually. Oh, I see. So they needed names. So when they said, hey, Charlie Brown, that meant the command module. They said, hey, Snoopy, that meant the lunar module. Right. So as somebody who's talked to a lot of these astronauts
吉恩·塞尔南在“史努比”里，那个不能在月球上着陆的登月舱，飞过月球表面上方仅仅几十英里，并自愿放弃着陆和回家的想法？我是说，你离得那么近，却不被允许停车去迪士尼乐园。你只能开车经过并看一眼。这就是他们叫它“查理·布朗”的原因吗？他们从来没到过那里。不，实际上，他们叫它“查理·布朗”的原因，是因为这是他们第一次必须有两个不同的航天器，他们必须单独与它们交谈。哦，我明白了。所以他们需要名字。所以当他们说，嘿，查理·布朗，那意味着指令舱。他们说，嘿，史努比，那意味着登月舱。对。所以作为一个与许多这些宇航员交谈过的人，
and obviously you've played astronauts and you've narrated films about them and so on and so forth. Is there a sense of, I mean, does the camaraderie trump everything? Are they just so proud and privileged to be doing the jobs that they are? Or is there a sense of,
显然你扮演过宇航员，你解说过关于他们的电影等等。有没有一种感觉，我是说，同志情谊是否胜过一切？他们是否只是为能做这份工作而感到如此自豪和荣幸？还是有一种感觉，
I don't know, maybe jealousy is too strong, but rivalry, you know, because the guy who gets to be the first guy on the moon, I mean, that is a very privileged position. So in other words, do the people on Apollo 10 think, yeah, this is all very well, but I wish I was on Apollo 11? Or does that not come into it? They are perhaps the most competitive group of people I've ever come across.
我不知道，也许嫉妒这个词太强烈了，但竞争，你知道，因为那个能成为第一个登上月球的人，我是说，那是一个非常特权的职位。所以换句话说，阿波罗10号上的人是否认为，是的，这都很好，但我希望我在阿波罗11号上？还是说那根本不涉及？他们可能是我遇到过的最有竞争力的群体。
Oh, really? They are all convinced, rightly so, that they are the most accomplished of anybody is there. They do give each other great respect for what they have accomplished, but they don't necessarily get along. Right. They don't necessarily have to like each other. Yeah. Without a doubt, it is a class. And by class, I mean a group of people who are all studying and competing for the same honors.
哦，真的吗？他们都确信，而且理所当然地认为，他们是所有人中最有成就的。他们确实对彼此所取得的成就给予了极大的尊重，但他们不一定相处得来。对。他们不一定非要喜欢对方。是的。毫无疑问，这是一个阶级。而通过阶级，我的意思是，一群都在学习并竞争相同荣誉的人。
Right. Yeah. And inside that comes every one of the human feelings that was part of the human condition. But what they also are, they are members of an extremely exclusive club that is a meritocracy. You have to be smart. You have to be accomplished. And you have to withstand any number of intellectual and physical rigors to be a part of it. So I have found them all to be a source of, if you can get them away from, what's the
对。是的。而在那里面包含了人类状况中所有的每一种人类情感。但他们也是一个极其排外的俱乐部的成员，这是一个精英管理制度。你必须聪明。你必须有成就。而且你必须承受任何数量的智力和身体上的严酷考验才能成为其中的一员。所以我发现他们都是一个来源，如果你能让他们远离，什么是
word I'm going, you know, anybody who accepts a check from the federal government runs the risk of saying something so, you know, improper or whatever. And so there's an awful lot of pressure on them to always say and be and do the right thing. I'll take that into account because I understand that what goes along with it. But just like, I don't know, it's kind of like when you get a chance to have a real conversation with one of the Rolling Stones, you know, hey, Bill Wyman, I got some questions for you about what it was like being a part of the Rolling Stones. Hey, Charlie, Charlie Watts, you got to watch the back of those. do you think you know they all have a very
我要说的词，你知道，任何接受联邦政府支票的人都有说出一些，你知道，不恰当的话的风险。所以他们身上有巨大的压力，总是要说、成为和做正确的事情。我会考虑到这一点，因为我理解随之而来的东西。但就像，我不知道，这有点像当你有机会与滚石乐队的成员进行真正的对话时，你知道，嘿，比尔·怀曼，我有一些关于作为滚石乐队一员是什么感觉的问题要问你。嘿，查理，查理·沃茨，你得小心那些。你认为你知道他们都有一个非常
very very individual story to tell about what they saw and what they went through and it is singular it is for them and them alone you know you you tom and dominic you talk about what would have happened if neil and buzz and ap Apollo 11 had died going down to the surface or not able to get off the surface. Let's imagine their corpses are in the sea of tranquility for the rest of time. Okay. Do you know what Michael Collins had to do? Michael Collins was the astronaut in the command module. He was there to take them home you know he had to drill and practice and come up with the plan in order to fly home by himself yeah and that was not just a theoretical thing written on paper yeah he had to run those simulations himself now you hear that that's like okay
非常非常独特的故事要讲，关于他们看到了什么以及他们经历了什么，它是独特的，它是为了他们和他们自己。你知道，你，汤姆和多米尼克，你们谈论如果尼尔和巴兹以及阿波罗11号在下降到表面时死亡或无法离开表面会发生什么。让我们想象他们的尸体在宁静海里永远存在。好吧。你知道迈克尔·柯林斯必须做什么吗？迈克尔·柯林斯是指令舱里的宇航员。他在那里带他们回家，你知道，他必须演练和练习，并想出一个计划，以便独自飞回家，是的，那不仅仅是写在纸上的理论东西，是的，他必须自己运行那些模拟。现在你听到这个，就像，好吧，
i think it's great that neil and buzz got to. I have some questions for Michael Collins I'd like to ask about what he went through. So let's not discount the expertise of those men simply because they didn't get to go down and get their boots dirty. But also, I mean, imagine Aldrin and Armstrong know that Michael Collins has been preparing for that. Michael Collins knows it. I mean, such courage. And just to go back to the letter that we opened with, they're getting in a tin can. They don't know it's going to work. So we should probably take a break. But before we do that, let's get man on the moon. So let's follow Neil Armstrong and Buzz Aldrin as they are coming down to the surface of the moon in the Eagle. As preparation for this i re-watched the the
我觉得尼尔和巴兹能做到太棒了。我有一些关于迈克尔·柯林斯的问题，我想问他关于他经历了什么。所以不要仅仅因为他们没有下去弄脏他们的靴子就贬低那些人的专业知识。但我也，我是说，想象一下奥尔德林和阿姆斯特朗知道迈克尔·柯林斯一直在为那个做准备。迈克尔·柯林斯知道它。我是说，多么大的勇气。而且只是回到我们开始的那封信，他们正在进入一个锡罐。他们不知道它会工作。所以我们可能应该休息一下。但在我们这样做之前，让我们让人类登上月球。所以让我们跟随尼尔·阿姆斯特朗和巴兹·奥尔德林，当他们乘坐“鹰号”下降到月球表面时。作为准备，我重看了
ryan gosling film first man and they do it brilliantly and i think it's kind of music it's kind of incredible tension yeah and i was prompted then to go and read a book that you wrote the introduction for andrew chaikin's a man on the moon the voyages of the apollo astronauts because i hadn't realized until i saw that film that they almost land in a crater, don't they? And Neil Armstrong has to kind of take over. He kind of goes... He says, pretty rocky area here, he said. Understatements of the year. Yeah. Pretty rocky area here. Well, yeah, yeah. On the moon. And the NASA tracking guy is saying it was like watching a man, some kind of snake charmer,
瑞恩·高斯林的电影《登月第一人》（First Man），他们做得非常出色，我认为这是一种音乐，这是一种不可思议的紧张感，是的，我当时受到启发去读了一本书，你为它写了序言，安德鲁·查金的《月球上的人：阿波罗宇航员的航行》，因为直到我看到那部电影，我才意识到他们差点降落在一个陨石坑里，对吧？而尼尔·阿姆斯特朗不得不接管。他有点……他说，这里相当多岩石，他说。年度最轻描淡写的说法。是的。这里相当多岩石。嗯，是的，是的。在月球上。而NASA的追踪人员说，这就像看着一个人，某种弄蛇人，
put his hand on a cobra. Anything can happen any minute and probably will. I mean, I cannot imagine the tension there must've been at that moment. There was also the fact that the visuals of landing there, because there is no atmosphere, there is no sense of depth perception. It's very hard to determine how big that rock actually is. Is it the size of a house? The size of a car? Is it the size of a toaster? How big is that rock? Because the lack of an atmosphere means everything is crystal clear. Everything is as sharp as focus as there is.
把他的手放在眼镜蛇上。任何事情随时都可能发生，而且很可能会发生。我是说，我无法想象那一刻一定有多么紧张。还有这样一个事实，在那里着陆的视觉效果，因为没有大气层，没有深度知觉。很难确定那块岩石实际上有多大。它是房子那么大吗？汽车那么大吗？它是烤面包机那么大吗？那块岩石有多大？因为缺乏大气层意味着一切都晶莹剔透。一切都像焦点一样清晰。
Outside of the analog radar, they had a very primitive version of radar, not much better than had it existed since World War II. The best guide they had was the fact they had the shadow of their lunar module. They had the shadow of the Eagle. And the math that went into them landing meant that their lunar module had to be coming into a landing with the sun directly behind them. So that this little shadow that finally shows up in the distance is them. And they just match it up for where they are until the shadows. I mean, just. And it's not until about 20 feet above the surface that the dust of the moon starts kicking
除了模拟雷达，他们有一个非常原始的雷达版本，并不比二战以来存在的雷达好多少。他们拥有的最好的指南是他们有登月舱的影子。他们有“鹰号”的影子。而他们着陆所涉及的数学意味着他们的登月舱必须在太阳直接在他们身后时进入着陆。这样，远处出现的这个小影子就是他们。他们只是匹配它，直到影子。我是说，只是。直到距离表面约20英尺，月球的尘埃开始踢
up and Buzz Aldrin says, picking up a little dust. That means they are that close. So a shadow and some dust is the only thing that tells them how close they are to the surface. I can't get past those kind of details. Yeah. Should we take a break now? And when we come back, we'll let the listeners know whether the eagle manages to land or not. Yeah, let's find out because I'm anxious to know. Okay. See you in a few minutes. Bye-bye. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman.
起来，巴兹·奥尔德林说，扬起了一点尘埃。这意味着他们离得那么近。所以影子和一些尘埃是唯一告诉他们离表面有多近的东西。我无法摆脱那些细节。是的。我们现在应该休息一下吗？当我们回来时，我们会让听众知道“鹰号”是否成功着陆。是的，让我们找出答案，因为我很想知道。好的。几分钟后再见。再见。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。
And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain
我们一起主持《历史余温》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这是你每周的娱乐新闻、评论、一点点演艺圈八卦的固定节目，在我们的问答环节，我们拉开帷幕
on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access
关于娱乐，我们告诉你它是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了我们的会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集和抢先访问
to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisent is entertainment.com that's the rest is entertainment.com welcome back to the rest is history we are still here with tom hanks talking about moonwalkers the men who walked on the moon so we're on july theth, 1969. A young Tom Hanks is watching in awe in California. I think that's right, isn't it? You're watching at home.
现场门票，前往 therestisentertainment.com。那是 therestisentertainment.com，那是 therestisentertainment.com，欢迎回到《历史余温》，我们仍然和汤姆·汉克斯在这里谈论《月球漫步者》，那些在月球上行走的人。所以我们是在1969年7月。年轻的汤姆·汉克斯在加州敬畏地看着。我想那是对的，不是吗？你在家里看。
Yes. You're watching a movie that flew to your TV like so many people. And they've been gone for four days. They have 30 seconds of fuel left in the reserves. The tension is mounting. I know. The world is watching. And Neil Armstrong brings the lunar module down and he cuts the engines and he says,
是的。你正在看一部像许多人一样飞到你电视上的电影。他们已经走了四天了。他们的储备燃料只剩下30秒了。紧张局势正在加剧。我知道。全世界都在看着。尼尔·阿姆斯特朗把登月舱降下来，他切断了引擎，他说，
the Eagle has landed. And the show at the Lightroom that you narrate, so Tom mentioned it earlier in the first half at King's Cross, you get a sense of this almost ecstatic joy and relief in the control room when they realize they're down they've made it and the next thing is actually getting a human being down the steps and onto the surface of the moon and am i right in saying that before they do that um buzz aldrin has some bread and wine and he wants to have a kind of a religious moment. Is that right? Yeah, he was about Catholic. And the interesting personalities of all of these crews, I think, comes out in Apollo 11, because I don't think you could have two individuals that are more different
“鹰”已着陆。你在Lightroom解说的那个展览，汤姆在前半部分提到了，在国王十字车站，当控制室里的人意识到他们着陆成功时，你会感受到一种近乎狂喜的快乐和解脱。接下来的事情就是让一个人走下台阶，踏上月球表面。我没说错吧，在他们做这件事之前，巴兹·奥尔德林吃了面包和酒，他想进行某种宗教仪式。是这样吗？是的，他是个天主教徒。我认为，阿波罗11号任务中所有这些机组成员有趣的个性都展现了出来，因为我觉得你找不到两个比尼尔·阿姆斯特朗和巴兹·奥尔德林性格差异更大的人了。
than Neil Armstrong was from Buzz Aldrin. And you chuck Michael Collins in there and you have, honestly, I'm not sure those guys would have volunteered to drive to the beach together had they not been assigned to it. But he did do it. And I think it's actually very beautiful, particularly for a man of any type of faith. And it does put that other sort of context into the endeavor. Now, NASA, I don't think was ever wild about there being any religiosity brought to anything in the program. In fact, when Apollo 8 read from the book of Genesis on their television broadcast,
尼尔·阿姆斯特朗和巴兹·奥尔德林之间的差异。如果你把迈克尔·柯林斯也加进去，老实说，我不确定如果不是被指派在一起，这些人是否会自愿一起开车去海边。但他们确实做到了。我认为这实际上非常美，特别是对于任何有信仰的人来说。这确实为这项事业增添了另一种背景。现在，我不认为美国国家航空航天局（NASA）曾经热衷于在计划中引入任何宗教色彩。事实上，当阿波罗8号在电视广播中朗读《创世纪》时，
there was all sorts of, you know, any number of public comments. They were like, this is the last thing we need. But I think what Buzz did there was he said, this is a personal moment that I am experiencing. So therefore, I am going to note it in a very, very personal way. And one way or another, in an awful lot of the conversations I've had, I haven't spoken to every one of the men who walked on the moon, but they all do some version of that. That is just a moment for themselves. But of course, for people watching that. That is just a moment for themselves.
有各种各样的，你知道，无数的公众评论。他们说，这是我们最不需要的东西。但我认为巴兹在那里所做的是，他说，这是我正在经历的一个个人时刻。因此，我将以一种非常、非常私人的方式记录它。不管怎样，在我进行的大量谈话中，我并没有和每一个登上过月球的人交谈过，但他们都做了某种类似的事情。那只是属于他们自己的时刻。但当然，对于在电视上观看的人来说，那只是属于他们自己的时刻。
But of course, for people watching on television, the key moment is when Neil Armstrong actually steps onto the moon. And he slightly fluffs his great line, doesn't he? Did you, as an actor, ever talk to him about that? There's all sorts of fabulous, you know, old wives tales or, you know, legends about what it is. And if he had said that's one small step for a man, one giant leap for all mankind, that might have been better. But for my view, it's one small step for man, a giant leap for mankind. There is a rule, I think, when it comes down to literature is to get rid of any word that you do not need. I think that he just truncated it perfectly. And maybe he was a little excited. Maybe his heart rate was a little large because I think
但当然，对于在电视上观看的人来说，关键时刻是尼尔·阿姆斯特朗真正踏上月球的那一刻。他稍微说错了那句伟大的台词，不是吗？作为一名演员，你有没有和他谈过这件事？关于那句话到底是什么，有各种各样精彩的，你知道，老掉牙的故事，或者说传说。如果他说的是“这是个人的一小步，却是全人类的一大步”，那可能会更好。但在我看来，它是“这是人的一小步，人类的一大步”。我认为在文学方面有一条规则，那就是删掉任何你不需要的词。我认为他只是完美地缩减了它。也许他有点兴奋。也许他的心率有点高，因为我认为
what he did not say, and I've heard fabulous jokes about this from various comedic outlets. What he did not say is, holy cow, I'm stepping on the moon. Oh my God, I can't frigging believe this. I'm standing on the goddamn moon. He didn't say that. So I think it ends up being as beautiful as anything that Shakespeare or Sophocles or Confucius or late Zhao has ever said, that you can't go much better than a giant leap for mankind. Right. And just to get back to the competitive thing that you talked about in the first half. Yeah.
他没说出口的话——我从各种喜剧节目中听到过关于此的精彩笑话——他没说的是：“天哪，我正踩在月球上。天哪，我简直不敢相信。我正站在该死的月球上。”他没这么说。所以我认为它最终变得和莎士比亚、索福克勒斯、孔子或老子所说的任何话一样优美，你不可能比“人类的一大步”说得更好了。没错。回到你前半部分谈到的竞争问题。是的。
Buzz Aldrin wanted to be the first man on the moon, did he not? Is it not right that when they said, listen, it's going to be Neil, that he was like, you know what? I think it actually should be me. Well, every single man who was in the astronaut corps wanted to be the first man to set foot on the moon. Al Shepard wanted it to be. Fred Hayes wanted it to be.
巴兹·奥尔德林想成为第一个登上月球的人，不是吗？当他们说“听着，将是尼尔”时，他是不是觉得“你知道吗？我觉得其实应该是我”。好吧，宇航员队伍中的每一个人都想成为第一个踏上月球的人。艾尔·谢泼德想，弗雷德·海斯也想。
Pete Conrad wanted it to be. And actually, he had a shot because if something had gone wrong with 11, he would have made the first landing on 12. Yeah. But there had been this hierarchy when it came down to who gets out of the spacecraft. On Gemini, for the first spacewalks of Ed White and Gene Cernan and Michael Collins made a spacewalk on Gemini with two guys. The commander stayed inside the craft, piloting it, and the pilot, the other guy, essentially popped the hatch and got out first.
皮特·康拉德也想。事实上，他有机会，因为如果11号出了什么问题，他就会成为12号的首次着陆者。是的。但在谁能走出航天器的问题上，一直存在着一种等级制度。在双子座计划中，埃德·怀特和吉恩·塞尔南的首次太空行走，以及迈克尔·柯林斯在双子座任务中与另外两人进行的太空行走，指挥官都留在舱内驾驶，而飞行员，也就是另一个人，基本上是打开舱门先出去。
That's the way it had always been in Gemini. And they would have assumed, you would have assumed, that that would be the case also when it came time to landing on the moon. Now, is it an odd detail of spacecraft design that the hinges of the door of the hatch of the lunar module made it impossible for the guy standing on the right hand side to get out first and instead be commander of the mission the guy who actually made the landing right i don't know that we will ever know if it was that or it could have been and
在双子座计划中一直都是这样。你会认为，当轮到登月时，情况也会如此。现在，月球舱舱门铰链的设计是否是一个奇怪的细节，使得站在右侧的人无法先出去，而必须是任务指挥官，也就是真正完成着陆的那个人先出去？我不知道我们是否会知道这是否是原因，或者可能是……
i'm i have no i have no detail that says this was the case. I wouldn't be surprised if when it came down to that decision and the design of the hatch itself that somebody, maybe it was Deke Slayton, maybe it was Chris Kraft. I don't believe anybody is going to be the commander of the first landings on the moon who's going to say, no, let the other guy get out. I'm the commander. I'm getting out. I just landed. So leave it to that. So is it because of the design of it or is it because of some greater discussion? The record,
我没有任何细节表明情况就是这样。如果当涉及到那个决定和舱门本身的设计时，有人——也许是迪克·斯莱顿，也许是克里斯·克拉夫特——说“我不相信会有任何人成为首次登月的指挥官，却会说‘不，让另一个人先出去’。我是指挥官。我要出去。我刚刚着陆了。所以就这样吧。”那么，这是因为设计原因，还是因为某种更宏大的讨论？记录，
I think, will probably go to show that, let's just call it a disappointment, that Buzz Aldrin was not the first one. I mean, who doesn't want to be the first man to walk on the boat? Yeah. And it was a piece that he had to make with himself and it took a long time probably for him to make that. Neil Armstrong was the best pilot, was he? I think in the entire space program. I mean, he had that reputation. Well, not if you ask all the other pilots. Well, yeah, sure. But then they didn't walk on the moon, did they? The first. Well, you know, Pete Conrad- But I guess there's also the sense. There's a sense also that he's the kind of guy you would want to be the first man to walk on the moon.
我想，可能会表明，我们姑且称之为一种失望，巴兹·奥尔德林不是第一个。我的意思是，谁不想成为第一个登上月球的人呢？是的。这是他必须与自己和解的一件事，他可能花了很长时间才做到这一点。尼尔·阿姆斯特朗是最好的飞行员，是吗？我认为在整个太空计划中是这样。我的意思是，他有那样的声誉。嗯，如果你问所有其他飞行员，他们可不这么认为。嗯，是的，当然。但他们没有登上月球，不是吗？第一个。嗯，你知道，皮特·康拉德……但我猜也有这样一种感觉。也有这样一种感觉，他就是那种你希望成为第一个登上月球的人。
He was a civilian. How about that? He was the only civilian. Everybody else, maybe not Jack Smith, but everybody else had been commissioned officers in the Navy as an aviator or the Air Force. Neil Armstrong was not. But he was going to play the first guy who walks on the moon is obviously, if he makes it back, he is going to be in the eye of the global media and he will be for the rest of his life.
他是一名平民。那又怎样？他是唯一的平民。其他人，也许杰克·施密特除外，但其他所有人都曾是海军飞行员或空军的委任军官。尼尔·阿姆斯特朗不是。但他将要扮演第一个登上月球的人，显然，如果他能平安回来，他将处于全球媒体的焦点，并且余生都将如此。
And so I guess you would want someone who could carry that off with dignity. And Neil Armstrong obviously did that tremendously. He certainly did. And I will say this, that came about because everything went according to plan. Plans that had shifted as early as December of 1968, when they decided to bypass the schedule of tests and missions. If, for example, anything had gone wrong, even on Apollo 10, even if Apollo 10 had not lived up to its specifications, Apollo 11 would have been a different sort of mission and would have been bombed. And Apollo 12 could have very easily have been the first mission to the moon. Or somebody else could have done something else.
所以我猜你会希望有一个能以尊严完成这件事的人。尼尔·阿姆斯特朗显然做得非常出色。他确实做到了。我还要说，这是因为一切都按计划进行。早在1968年12月，当他们决定绕过测试和任务的时间表时，计划就已经改变了。例如，如果出了什么问题，即使是在阿波罗10号上，即使阿波罗10号没有达到其规格要求，阿波罗11号也会是另一种任务，并且会失败。而阿波罗12号很可能很容易成为第一次登月任务。或者其他人可能会做别的事情。
They would have slid it around. It's an interesting question of what was the guarantee that Neil and Buzz and Mike Collins were going to be the mission that landed first on the moon. Because even Al Shepard's Apollo 14, they were originally going to be Apollo 13, but that got slipped for any number of reasons. So there's a period of time where the schedule is in flux. But they make it back. They do. And they lived up to that second important part. Land a man on the moon. And get back. And return them safely to the earth.
他们会调整时间表。这是一个有趣的问题，是什么保证了尼尔、巴兹和迈克·柯林斯会成为第一批登上月球的任务组？因为即使是艾尔·谢泼德的阿波罗14号，他们最初也是阿波罗13号，但由于各种原因被推迟了。所以有一段时间时间表是不确定的。但他们成功回来了。他们做到了。他们完成了第二个重要的部分：让人类登上月球。并回来。并将他们安全送回地球。
Yeah. Let's look at them and just the physics of that. Okay. All right. They have landed on the moon. They have to ascend back up into orbit around the moon. There's a lot of math involved in that, a lot of technology, meaning that rocket has to work perfectly. That rocket engine, all those valves and all the pressure and all the mixture and all the glycols and all that kind of stuff has to work perfectly. The command module has to be in the right place and it's got to hook up. They've got to be able to get back together, stow everything in, then they throw away that ascent station then they have to line up perfectly and come home to earth and how many shots do they have at that they have one single shot they
是的。让我们看看他们以及其中的物理原理。好吧。好吧。他们已经在月球上着陆了。他们必须上升回到月球轨道。这其中涉及大量的数学计算，大量的技术，意味着火箭必须完美运行。那个火箭发动机，所有的阀门、所有的压力、所有的混合物、所有的乙二醇以及所有这些东西都必须完美运行。指令舱必须在正确的位置，并且必须对接。他们必须能够重新汇合，把所有东西收好，然后抛弃那个上升段，然后他们必须完美地对齐并回家。他们有多少次机会？他们只有一次机会，他们
essentially come back from the moon on a clothesline straight through going i don't even you guys might be able to how fast is the uh as the spacecraft going as it comes backwards? Something like 55,000 miles an hour? Dominic will know. Dominic, you got those numbers for us? I don't have them immediately to hand them. Okay, all right. Tom, that was very mean. But it's going.
基本上是从月球回来，就像在晾衣绳上一样直冲过来……我甚至不知道你们能不能……航天器在倒退时速度有多快？大约每小时55,000英里？多米尼克会知道的。多米尼克，你有这些数据吗？我手头没有。好吧，好吧。汤姆，这太刻薄了。但它确实在运行。
It's thousands and thousands of miles per hour, right? Because the gravitational pull of the Earth is pulling them even faster and faster and faster. And then they have to survive that fiery thing, The gravitational pull of the Earth is pulling them even faster and faster and faster. And then they have to survive that fiery thing. And then the parachutes all have to work and they can't drown in the middle of the Pacific Ocean and all this stuff. So can I ask you, so Apollo 11 succeeds and then Apollo 12 and men land on the moon and come back and it's all brilliant. But of course, Apollo 13 famously, things go wrong. And everything that you've been talking about is essentially what the character that you
它是每小时几千英里，对吧？因为地球的引力在拉着他们越来越快。然后他们必须在那场火热的考验中幸存下来……地球的引力在拉着他们越来越快。然后他们必须在那场火热的考验中幸存下来。然后降落伞必须全部打开，他们不能淹死在太平洋中间，所有这些事情。所以我能问你吗，阿波罗11号成功了，然后是阿波罗12号，人类登上月球并回来，一切都很精彩。但当然，阿波罗13号出了名地出了问题。你一直在谈论的一切基本上就是你
play in that film has to deal with. I assume that having played Jim Lovell, it gave you a much sharper sense of everything that was at stake, not just in Apollo 13, but in all the missions. The question that I think everybody asks, and I might have asked it of Jim himself, hey, how scared were you? And the truth is no more scared than any other time they'd gone up in an airplane and figured out, oh, something could go wrong when I'm up here. On Apollo 13, the crew knew exactly what they were going to have to do. They were going to have to treat the lunar module Aquarius as a lifeboat. That was the engine that they had. And that was a contingency to a degree.
在电影中扮演的角色必须处理的事情。我想扮演吉姆·洛威尔让你对所有风险有了更深刻的认识，不仅是在阿波罗13号中，而且在所有任务中。我认为每个人都会问的问题，我也可能问过吉姆本人：“嘿，你有多害怕？”事实是，并不比他们驾驶飞机时担心的多，他们知道“哦，我在上面时可能会出问题”。在阿波罗13号上，机组人员确切地知道他们必须做什么。他们必须把登月舱“水瓶座”号当作救生艇。那是他们拥有的发动机。在某种程度上，那是一个应急方案。
And after that, I said, well, did you ever have those type of moments where you were just sitting there thinking, we're screwed? And he said, no, because there was always something to do. He described it as a long, long game of solitaire. You could always go three cards and see three cards and see nothing three oh no i can do this here we need to do that here there was a thing with the uh taking the o2 out of the out of the atmosphere there was always something they could do fred hayes uh played by bill paxton the late bill paxton good friend he said you know sometimes the only thing to do was just to switch over to the forward omni radio antenna because they were they were spinning around in space and so they always had
在那之后，我说：“好吧，你有没有过那种时刻，你只是坐在那里想，我们完蛋了？”他说：“没有，因为总有事情要做。”他把它描述为一场漫长的纸牌游戏。你总是可以翻三张牌，看到三张牌，什么都没看到……哦，不，我可以做这个，我们需要在那里做那个。有一个关于从大气中去除氧气的问题，总有他们能做的事情。弗雷德·海斯——由已故的比尔·帕克斯顿饰演，他是我的好朋友——他说：“你知道，有时唯一能做的就是切换到前向全向无线电天线，因为他们在太空中旋转，所以他们总是
to have the the antenna turned on that was pointing at the earth sometimes he said that's all i had to do but you know that gave me something to do every two and a half minutes so yeah that was something, that was something like that. So getting to that aspect where they are always in play, and as long as they had a step that they had to take, they realized that there was a chance that they were going to make it back. The bigger thing I think that I certainly get from Jim Lovell, and he said this, he said, anytime you go up in an airplane, you cheat death. Human beings aren't meant to fly, but we've just figured out how to do this. Human beings aren't supposed to go up into outer space. And by the way, when he flew on Apollo 13, he was the most traveled man in the history of humankind. He had been in space more
必须打开指向地球的天线。有时他说，这就是我所要做的。但你知道，这让我每两分半钟就有事可做。所以是的，就是那样，就是那样。所以，谈到他们总是处于行动中的那个方面，只要他们有必须采取的步骤，他们就意识到他们有机会成功回来。我认为我从吉姆·洛威尔那里得到的更重要的一点是，他说过，任何时候你驾驶飞机，你都在与死神博弈。人类本不该飞行，但我们刚刚找到了实现这一目标的方法。人类本不该进入外太空。顺便说一句，当他执行阿波罗13号任务时，他是人类历史上旅行最远的人。他在太空中待的时间更
often. He had been in space longer. He had gone farther than anybody else up to that point because that was his second flight to the moon because he'd been on Apollo 8. I really got from him the tactile understanding that at the end of the day, it's flesh and blood and brains that make all of this stuff possible. Yeah. And we always had our brains and our flesh and blood was still intact. That's all they needed in order to have faith in themselves. Faith in themselves, I think, is the great divisive part between people that achieve things and those who don't even try. It's the difference between us and rival
久。他待的时间更长。他比当时任何人都走得更远，因为那是他第二次飞往月球，因为他参加过阿波罗8号。我真正从他那里得到的是一种触觉上的理解，归根结底，是血肉之躯和大脑让这一切成为可能。是的。我们总是有我们的大脑，我们的血肉之躯依然完好无损。这就是他们需要的一切，以便对自己有信心。我认为，对自己有信心是那些取得成就的人与那些甚至不去尝试的人之间最大的分歧所在。这就是我们与竞争对手
history podcasts, isn't it, Tom? Exactly right. I like to think so. So when you talk about Jim Lovell and you talk about how well-traveled he was, I mean, that's an extraordinary thought, isn't it? He's the most well-traveled man in human history to that point. And you get a sense of the awesome scale of their achievements and the sense of possibility. I mean, they are doing this year after year, multiple times a year sometimes. So Apollo 13 is what, 1970? And then you have 14, 15, 16, 17, and they're playing golf on the moon. Well, yeah. Apollo 15, they have playing golf on the moon. Well, yeah. Apollo 15, they have a lunar rover.
历史播客之间的区别，不是吗，汤姆？完全正确。我也这么认为。所以当你谈到吉姆·洛威尔，谈到他旅行得有多远时，我的意思是，那是一个非凡的想法，不是吗？他是人类历史上到那时为止旅行最远的人。你感受到了他们成就的巨大规模和可能性的感觉。我的意思是，他们年复一年地这样做，有时一年多次。所以阿波罗13号是哪一年？1970年？然后是14、15、16、17号，他们在月球上打高尔夫球。嗯，是的。阿波罗15号，他们在月球上打高尔夫球。嗯，是的。阿波罗15号，他们有一辆月球车。
They have effectively a car on the moon. A fold-up electric car. Now, how about that? Yeah. Someone said, hey, you know, it'd be great if we could see a little bit more on the moon and help these guys. How can we get a car up there? And someone says, I know. Let's build one that folds up.
他们实际上在月球上有一辆车。一辆可折叠的电动车。现在，那怎么样？是的。有人说：“嘿，你知道，如果我们能在月球上多看一点，帮助这些人，那该多好。我们怎么能把车弄上去？”有人说：“我知道。让我们造一辆能折叠的车。”
Right. we get a car up there and someone says i know let's build one that folds up right and so you'll just have to pull this little cord and it'll pop open up on the moon you have four wheels and all the all the stuff and they can drive as far as they want to i uh the the guys they were called the j missions right 14 excuse me 15 16 and. Not only did they have this electric car, but they were going to spend three working days out on the moon. Neil and Buzz were on the lunar surface for about two hours. That's it. And by the way, the Soviet Union, had they been the first to land on the moon,
对。我们把车弄上去，有人说我知道让我们造一辆能折叠的车，对吧？所以你只需要拉一下这根小绳子，它就会在月球上弹开，你有四个轮子和所有的东西，他们想开多远就开多远。我……那些人被称为J任务，对吧？14，抱歉，15、16和。他们不仅有这辆电动车，而且他们要在月球上度过三个工作日。尼尔和巴兹在月球表面待了大约两个小时。就是这样。顺便说一句，苏联，如果他们是第一个登上月球的，
they wouldn't have even been able to walk more than a few yards from their spacecraft because they would have been connected by an umbilical cord. Is that so? They would have picked up some rocks. Right. They would have picked up some rocks and dust, planted a flag, the hammer and the sickle, and they would have done a couple of other things.
他们甚至无法从航天器上走开几码，因为他们会被脐带连接着。是这样吗？他们会捡起一些岩石。对。他们会捡起一些岩石和灰尘，插上一面旗帜，锤子和镰刀，他们还会做其他几件事。
And then they would have got back and they would have come home. Their plan was not necessarily to explore the moon. So Neil and Buzz are out for one spacewalk about two hours pete conrad and al bean they did two spacewalks on apollo 12 spent the night uh and then and then took off by the way also made a pinpoint landing because they landed right next to a the surveyor probe yeah apollo 13 didn't make it apollo 14 did what Apollo 13 was going to do. And what they wanted to do was go to a different sort of geological formation on the moon to see the difference between the rocks. They were in the Fraumura Islands. Then along comes 15, 16, and 17.
然后他们就会返回，回到家中。他们的计划并不一定是为了探索月球。所以尼尔和巴兹进行了一次大约两小时的太空行走，皮特·康拉德和艾尔·比恩在阿波罗12号上进行了两次太空行走，过了一夜，然后起飞。顺便说一下，他们还进行了精确着陆，因为他们降落在了测量员探测器旁边。是的，阿波罗13号没能成功，阿波罗14号完成了阿波罗13号原本要做的事情。他们想做的是去月球上一种不同的地质构造，看看岩石之间的区别。他们在弗拉·毛罗高地。接着是15号、16号和17号。
It's like, go as far as you can, find as much as the stuff, and land in the most difficult places, and let's find out what is there every time they did that every one of those missions tested some new aspect of what it takes for human beings to go into outer space and prove that either worked or did not work and i think i think they all found you know a surprisingly uh great amount of leeway i'll tell you this let. Let's just ponder their pressure suits, the lunar, LEVA suits, lunar excursion suits that they had, the pressure suits. They worked perfectly. The worst thing that happened was on Apollo 14, the water hose got crimped,
就像是，尽可能走得远，找到尽可能多的东西，降落在最困难的地方，让我们看看那里有什么。他们每次这样做，这些任务中的每一个都测试了人类进入外太空所需的新方面，并证明了它是有效的还是无效的。我认为他们都发现了令人惊讶的巨大回旋余地。我告诉你这个，让我们思考一下他们的压力服，月球舱外活动服，他们拥有的那些压力服。它们工作得非常完美。发生的最糟糕的事情是在阿波罗14号上，水管被挤压了，
and the astronaut was not able to replenish himself with liquids while he was out on the moon for seven hours. Then here's a very interesting detail. And let's not discount that. I was in the lunar special and receiving laboratory where they still have the rocks from the moon, geological samples from the moon that have not been touched. They have not been examined. I mean, most of them have been, but underneath gloves, inside a vacuum-packed seal in an airtight antiseptic atmosphere, I was
宇航员在月球上待了七个小时，却无法补充液体。这是一个非常有趣的细节。我们不要忽视这一点。我曾在月球特别接收实验室，那里仍然保存着月球上的岩石，即尚未被触碰过的月球地质样本。它们还没有被检查过。我的意思是，大多数都已经检查过了，但在手套下，在真空包装的密封件内，在密封的防腐环境中，我
able to hold the packages that had moon rocks in them. And the geologist that was there said to me something fascinating. He said, you know, 90% of what we know about lunar geology came from the rocks that Neil Armstrong picked up. On Apollo 11, Neil picked up the lunar specimens. Buzz laid out the scientific packages. So 90% of our understanding, our education of geological origins and makeup of stuff on the moon came from the rocks that Neil Armstrong picked up in his two hours. So you got to think then, what were all those missions for? To find out what was possible, to find out the limits of how far one could go and to find out the other specifications that is going to be the template for how anybody goes into outer space
能够拿着装有月球岩石的包裹。在那里的地质学家对我说了些令人着迷的话。他说，你知道，我们对月球地质学的了解有90%来自尼尔·阿姆斯特朗捡回来的岩石。在阿波罗11号上，尼尔捡回了月球标本。巴兹布置了科学实验包。所以我们对月球地质起源和物质构成的理解和教育，90%来自尼尔·阿姆斯特朗在他那两个小时里捡回来的岩石。所以你得想一想，所有这些任务是为了什么？为了找出什么是可能的，找出一个人能走多远的极限，并找出将成为任何人进入外太空模板的其他规范。
yeah and you talk about them bringing stuff back like the lunar rocks but they also left things there didn't they oh so there's a lovely story i remember it from the the light room show that you did uh charlie duke he leaves a photo doesn't he um with an inscription with his family's fingerprints and the and the inscription on the photo says this is the family of astronaut charlie duke from planet earth who landed on the moon on april the 20th 1972 i actually found that the most because i'm sentimental i found that the most kind of poignant bit of the whole exhibition this photo which now has been bleached by the sun so the sun yeah so like the flags as well have been bleached yeah Yeah. On one side of that photograph is probably just a white blotch. But on the other side that has been sitting in darkness since 1972
是的，你说他们带回了东西，比如月球岩石，但他们也把东西留在了那里，不是吗？哦，有一个可爱的故事，我记得是在你做的那个灯光秀里。查理·杜克留下了一张照片，不是吗？上面有铭文，还有他家人的指纹，照片上的铭文写着：这是来自地球的宇航员查理·杜克的家人，他于1972年4月20日降落在月球上。实际上，因为我多愁善感，我觉得这是整个展览中最令人心酸的部分。这张照片现在已经被太阳漂白了，所以太阳，是的，就像旗帜一样，也被漂白了。是的。那张照片的一面可能只是一片白斑。但另一面，自1972年以来一直处于黑暗中，
are the names and the thumbprints of his family. So let's imagine that we're long gone and somebody else comes along to the moon. What do they notice? There's plenty of flags. There's a number of books. There's a Bible was left on the lunar rover. Plenty of scribbles of initials probably are here and there. There's that sculpture of the fallen astronaut that Dave Scott left because by that time, human lives had been lost in the space program.
是他的家人的名字和拇指印。所以让我们想象一下，我们早已不在了，而其他人来到了月球。他们会注意到什么？那里有很多旗帜。有很多书。月球车上留下了一本圣经。到处可能都有很多首字母的涂鸦。还有戴夫·斯科特留下的那个倒下的宇航员雕塑，因为到那时，太空计划中已经有人丧生了。
And that was representative of them. Everybody, you know, if you want to go on the internet, you'll be able to see that there's an entire market for lunar Apollo memorabilia, everything from patches that had been flown, you know, stowed away and flown to and from the moon, autographs signed, flight plans, this and that. That stuff is all scattered about and i don't know that everybody is willing to talk about this stuff that they took up with them and they brought back and i think there's a lot of very personal mementos that uh the 12 moonwalkers
那代表了他们。每个人，你知道，如果你想上网，你会发现有一个完整的阿波罗月球纪念品市场，从飞过的补丁，你知道，被收起来并飞往月球又带回来的，签名的签名，飞行计划，等等。那些东西都散落在各处，我不知道每个人是否都愿意谈论他们带上去又带回来的这些东西，我认为有许多非常私人的纪念品，那12位登月者
took up with them and brought back and gave off as very, very special gifts and historic ones. Because, I mean, imagine if you could come back with, you know, a fork from Columbus's original. Oh, wow. Yeah, sure. You might want to say this fork was, you know, was used on Magellan's, you know, trip around the world. That would be a very unique fork. So, Tom, you said 12 men walk on the moon, and the Apollo missions end in 1972. So no human has set foot on the moon since then. Could we end, I mean, I know this is a history podcast, but just ask you to look into the future and what your hopes would be for the future of human space travel and perhaps going to the moon and perhaps,
带上去又带回来，并作为非常、非常特别和具有历史意义的礼物送出。因为，我的意思是，想象一下如果你能带回哥伦布最初航行时用过的一把叉子。哦，哇。是的，当然。你可能会想说这把叉子是在麦哲伦环球旅行时用过的。那将是一把非常独特的叉子。所以，汤姆，你说有12个人在月球上行走，阿波罗任务在1972年结束。所以从那时起就没有人类踏上过月球。我们能结束吗，我的意思是，我知道这是一个历史播客，但只是想请你展望未来，你对人类太空旅行的未来，也许是去月球，也许是，
who knows, going to Mars? I found out recently that even just for the next 12-month period, I think there's something like 24 different enterprises that are going to go back to the moon. 24 different entities are going to land something there, plant something there, figure out how to put a probe down a robot, whatever. And it just happened, what, like a week and a half ago. Somebody landed on the moon and thing fell over. So it's now laying on its side. So I want to say the desire to go back, but I also would say the need for us to return to the moon is as present now as it was to get there in the first place. It is still there and it holds opportunity. Sure. Someone is, you know, I just, I just read the other day that somebody is going to try to go up and put a robotic tractor up there
谁知道呢，去火星，有什么希望？我最近发现，即使只是在接下来的12个月里，我想大约有24个不同的企业要回到月球。24个不同的实体要在那儿降落什么，种植什么，弄清楚如何放置一个探测器、一个机器人，等等。就在大约一周半前发生了这件事。有人降落在月球上，东西倒了。所以它现在侧躺着。所以我想说回归的愿望，但我也想说我们重返月球的必要性现在和当初到达那里时一样迫切。它仍然存在，并且蕴含着机会。当然。有人，你知道，我前几天刚读到，有人要尝试上去并在那里放置一个机器人拖拉机，
that is going to try to harvest the helium three isotope. You guys can have a whole podcast about the potential for helium three isotope. Oh, we'd a whole podcast about the potential for Helium-3 isotope. Oh, we'd love that. Dominic talks of little else, I have to say. Wouldn't that be fun? By the way, book that show and then just get ready for record-setting listeners coming in. Yeah, we will. I don't want to miss that Helium-3 podcast on The Rest Is History. You got to get that. So the opportunities go out there, it exists, but what you really are going to be coming around to that same sense of humanity, the same human need to continue along the track
试图收获氦-3同位素。你们可以做一个关于氦-3同位素潜力的完整播客。哦，我们会做一个关于氦-3同位素潜力的完整播客。哦，我们很乐意。多米尼克几乎只谈论这个，我必须说。那不是很棒吗？顺便说一下，预订那个节目，然后准备好迎接创纪录的听众。是的，我们会做的。我不想错过《历史的其余部分》中关于氦-3的播客。你一定要做那个。所以机会就在那里，它存在，但你真正要回归的是同样的人性，同样的人类需求，继续沿着
of what's up there. And so do you think it matters that it would be humans rather than say robots? I mean, is it something about it being flesh and blood that matters for scientific reasons or perhaps imaginative reasons, making a statement? Because that's what's so moving about the physical constraints on human beings. Yeah. Makes it more impressive. I mean, it's the flesh and blood. Yeah. It will be both.
上面的轨道前进。那么你认为人类而不是机器人去重要吗？我的意思是，是因为它是血肉之躯，出于科学原因，或者也许是出于想象的原因，做出某种声明？因为这就是人类身体限制所带来的感人之处。是的。这让它更令人印象深刻。我的意思是，是血肉之躯。是的。两者都会有。
It's not either or, because human beings will not accept either or. Tell human beings they not accept either or. Tell human beings they can't do something and then see how big the line is for the people who said, don't tell me what I can't do. Now, will human beings walk on the moon funded by governments and by popular will or by votes of Congress or parliament or whatever? Maybe not. What we have learned from the Apollo missions is literally how to do it. And how to do it does not necessarily have the need for huge, massive space consortiums in order to do it.
这不是非此即彼，因为人类不会接受非此即彼。告诉人类他们不能接受非此即彼。告诉人类他们不能做某事，然后看看那些说“别告诉我我不能做什么”的人排队有多长。现在，人类会由政府、民意、国会或议会的投票等资助在月球上行走吗？也许不会。我们从阿波罗任务中学到的是如何真正做到这一点。而如何做到这一点并不一定需要庞大的太空财团才能完成。
I mean, a husband and wife with the right amount of money and the right amount of smarts and enough land could probably do it themselves right now if they set out in order to do it. The technology is there. The technology is there. The physics is understood. The composites, the building materials, the computers, all that stuff is right there. The question will always still be to what purpose? It certainly isn't just to go back and we did it. And here I am and now I'm going to come back and I'll have my own podcast for the rest of the time because I'm the guy right back to the moon. The Artemis mission, you know, that's that's going to probably go up and circumnavigate, fly around the moon sometime next year.
我的意思是，一对有足够资金、足够聪明才智和足够土地的夫妻，如果他们下定决心，现在可能就能自己做到。技术就在那里。技术就在那里。物理学是已知的。复合材料、建筑材料、计算机，所有这些东西都在那里。问题永远是：为了什么目的？肯定不仅仅是为了回去说我们做到了。然后我在这里，现在我要回来，我余下的时间里会有我自己的播客，因为我是那个回到月球的人。阿尔忒弥斯任务，你知道，那很可能会在明年某个时候升空并环绕月球飞行。
That's going to be literally the first footstep toward some brand of recovery if if all the funding and everything holds out like that. But even without that, there are folks out there, maybe they're only eight years old, or maybe there's somebody who's 67 like I am, that's going to say, I'm not going to miss out on the opportunity to go back and restart or to take up again the mantle of what those first 12 human beings did. It's time for us to go back. We have never let a single piece of our planet Earth remain unexplored. I mean, there's people who live in Antarctica, you know, because there's stuff to figure out there. We've never done that. And we're not going to do that with something as close as our nearest celestial neighbor either.
那将是迈向某种恢复的第一步，如果所有的资金和一切都能维持下去的话。但即使没有这些，也有一些人，也许他们只有八岁，或者也许有人像我一样67岁，会说，我不会错过回到过去或重新承担起那最初12个人所做的事情的机会。是我们回去的时候了。我们从未让地球上的任何一个角落保持未被探索的状态。我的意思是，有人住在南极洲，你知道，因为那里有东西需要弄清楚。我们从未那样做过。我们也不会对像我们最近的天体邻居那样近的地方这样做。
Because once we get up there, we say, well, why do it? Because it's just going to be the next step towards whatever is beyond. And, you know, I love the scientific, the science fiction aspects of, and then we'll go to Mars and we'll figure out that. And then we'll go on here. Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. We'll do all that. That's great. Somebody else is going to go off and do it for the reasons that human beings will want to go to the moon in order to accomplish what needs to be accomplished. And I think that's fascinating. And will it happen? Look, I hope it happens within the next 10 years. It's got a really good shot. And if it happens within the next 10 years, it's just going to keep happening and keep happening and keep happening until it becomes as routine as flying from long Island in New York city into Paris, just like Charles Lindbergh did it, or, you know, being able to get on a seven 47 and flying from Los Angeles to Sydney, it will become something
因为一旦我们到了那里，我们会说，好吧，为什么要这样做？因为它只是通往超越一切的下一步。而且，你知道，我喜欢科幻小说中关于“然后我们将去火星，我们将弄清楚那个。然后我们将去这里”的方面。是的，是的，是的，是的。我们会做所有这些。那太棒了。其他人会为了人类想要去月球以完成需要完成的事情的原因而去。我认为这很迷人。这会发生吗？看，我希望它在未来10年内发生。它有很好的机会。如果它在未来10年内发生，它就会不断发生，不断发生，直到它变得像从纽约长岛飞往巴黎一样常规，就像查尔斯·林德伯格所做的那样，或者，你知道，能够登上747飞机从洛杉矶飞往悉尼，它将成为某件事，
that is like, Oh yeah. Oh, Oh, some, Oh, someone's got flew back on the moon. Oh, who did it this time? And maybe they'll pay attention and maybe they won't. But it will be being done by people who are phenomenally invested in the enterprise itself. So more people will choose to go to the moon and they will do it not because it is easy. They'll do it because it is hard. That's a brilliantly optimistic. We don't normally end the Restless History episodes
就像，哦，是的。哦，哦，有人飞回月球了。哦，这次是谁做的？也许他们会关注，也许不会。但它将由那些对企业本身投入巨大的人来完成。所以更多的人会选择去月球，他们这样做不是因为这很容易。他们这样做是因为这很难。这真是极其乐观。我们通常不会以乐观的基调结束《历史的其余部分》剧集，
on an optimistic note. Optimistically? Okay, well. But so, Tom, before we let you go, and thank you so much again for coming on the Restless History, our beloved producer, Theo, has banned us from saying goodbye to you
乐观地？好吧，那么。但是，汤姆，在我们让你走之前，再次非常感谢你来到《历史的其余部分》，我们敬爱的制片人西奥禁止我们和你告别，
until we've asked you a few questions about history. Bring it on. Don't worry, they're not quiz questions. All right. So I have my hand on the buzzer now. Okay, very good. Were you interested in history as a child?
直到我们问你几个关于历史的问题。放马过来吧。别担心，它们不是测验题。好的。所以我现在把手放在蜂鸣器上。好的，非常好。你小时候对历史感兴趣吗？
And if so, what particular bits of history did it for you? Is this my starter for 10, Dominic? I just want to make sure. Exactly so. Get this wrong and you're out. Yes, I've always been fascinated by history. For some reason, I didn't have to take notes in history classes. I just felt as though with a good teacher, I was hearing a story that was
如果是这样，哪些特定的历史片段吸引了你？这是我的入门题吗，多米尼克？我只是想确认一下。正是如此。答错你就出局了。是的，我一直对历史很着迷。出于某种原因，我不需要在历史课上做笔记。我只是觉得，如果有一位好老师，我听到的故事是
kind of like unforgettable. Math was beyond myself. I was too lazy for English. But history, it always used to be a version of a great story that I was hearing. And I think I was aware, I guess, as a young man, that I was living in historic times. First of all, and I've gone back and I've revisited certainly World War II, the war, because every adult in my life talked about the war in three very distinctive phases. That was before the war, that was during the war, or that was right after the war. So I knew that I had come into the world after this great conflagration that had really identified this entire generation. I was aware of that. Then when I was seven, John F. Kennedy was assassinated. And to be seven years old and to witness something that was the equal to, I don't know, Pearl Harbor or Hiroshima or the assassination of Abraham Lincoln, any incredible moment of history, it's like, wow, I witnessed that. And I don't think I'll ever forget where I was when I heard about it, nor the atmosphere of those three or four or five or six
那种令人难忘的故事。数学对我来说太难了。我对英语太懒了。但历史，它总是像我听到的一个伟大故事的版本。我想我作为一个年轻人，意识到我生活在历史性的时代。首先，我回去重温了第二次世界大战，因为我生命中的每个成年人都以三种非常独特的阶段谈论战争。那是战前，那是战中，或者那是战后。所以我知道我是在这场真正定义了整整一代人的大冲突之后来到这个世界的。我意识到了这一点。然后当我七岁时，约翰·F·肯尼迪被暗杀了。作为一个七岁的孩子，目睹了一件等同于，我不知道，珍珠港事件、广岛事件或亚伯拉罕·林肯遇刺，任何不可思议的历史时刻，就像，哇，我目睹了那个。我不认为我会忘记我听到这个消息时在哪里，也不会忘记那三、四、五或六
days that went along with it. The world was sad, and I was sad too, because history had occurred in front of our very eyes. Now, after that, I will tell you, and this is no joke, I was very much of the historical impact of four lads from Liverpool that came over not long after that. Oh, very good. Brilliant. Because they removed from us that burden of sadness that the assassination of John F. Kennedy had placed upon us. We literally were reintroduced to joy when we needed it very, very badly. Now that my generation, but actually the generation of probably anybody from seven to 27 was aware of the, hey, a corner has turned. So I've always thought that, well, is this a historic moment or not? I'll go back to
天里的气氛。世界很悲伤，我也很悲伤，因为历史就在我们眼前发生了。现在，在那之后，我会告诉你，这不是开玩笑，我深受四个利物浦小伙子带来的历史影响，他们在那之后不久就过来了。哦，非常好。太棒了。因为他们消除了约翰·F·肯尼迪遇刺带给我们的悲伤负担。当我们非常、非常需要快乐时，我们确实被重新引入了快乐。现在那是我这一代人，但实际上可能是从7岁到27岁的任何一代人都意识到了，嘿，一个转折点已经到来。所以我一直认为，嗯，这是一个历史性时刻吗？我会回到
that crossing of a Rubicon image. It's like, hey, we have crossed the Rubicon. We used to be over there, but now we're over here. Dominic and I disagree about whether the Beatles are a historic moment. So I'm glad that you agree with me that they are. I never disagreed with you. That's a total lie. Oh, no, Dominic. So you mentioned Lincoln there and you mentioned JFK. Can we just ask you, if you had a choice, which US president would you most like to play? Oh, none. I've read a very interesting book about Calvin Coolidge. You ready for this?
那个跨越卢比孔河的形象。就像，嘿，我们已经跨越了卢比孔河。我们过去在那边，但现在我们在这边。多米尼克和我对于披头士乐队是否是一个历史性时刻有分歧。所以我很高兴你同意我的观点，他们是。我从来没有不同意你的观点。那是彻头彻尾的谎言。哦，不，多米尼克。所以你提到了林肯，也提到了肯尼迪。我们能问你，如果有选择的话，你最想扮演哪位美国总统吗？哦，没有。我读过一本关于卡尔文·柯立芝的非常有趣的书。准备好了吗？
I didn't see that coming. Yeah. Didn't see that coming. Yeah. Calvin Coolidge, I think, forgive me, I may be wrong about it. I believe Calvin Coolidge, nothing much more than, he was like the governor of Vermont and ended up serving as president of the United States for two terms, during which the country was almost destroyed economically. And in this collection of essays in a volume, I read that he lived out his life, Calvin Coolidge, retired back in his Vermont small town. And he apologized to people for what he had done as president,
我没预料到会这样。是的。没预料到会这样。是的。卡尔文·柯立芝，我想，原谅我，我可能错了。我相信卡尔文·柯立芝，没什么比这更多的了，他就像佛蒙特州的州长，最终担任了两届美国总统，在此期间国家在经济上几乎被摧毁。在这一卷论文集中，我读到他过完了他的一生，卡尔文·柯立芝，退休回到了他的佛蒙特小镇。他向人们道歉，为他作为总统所做的事情，
because he had a very laissez-faire, hands-off kind of thing. He knew that he was a root cause of the great debacle that turned into the Great Depression in 1929. And that sort of self-awareness from a politician, I think somebody to be that humble at the end of his life saying, I'm sorry, I blew it. Sorry, I should have been on it better. I hope that's true. That is a tremendous choice. So there you go.
因为他有一种非常自由放任、不干涉的态度。他知道他是导致1929年大萧条的那场大灾难的根本原因。那种来自政治家的自我意识，我认为有人能在生命尽头如此谦卑地说，对不起，我搞砸了。抱歉，我本应该做得更好。我希望这是真的。这是一个了不起的选择。所以给你。
I'm declaring right here. The rest is history. Okay. If you have a movie about Calvin Coolidge, sign me up. That's got Blockbuster written all over it. So what about, because I know you do production as well. If you went to some you know big studio or whatever and they said listen tom we want a historical epic but the
我在这里宣布。《历史的其余部分》。好的。如果你有一部关于卡尔文·柯立芝的电影，算我一个。那上面写着大片的名字。那么，因为我知道你也做制片，如果你去某个你知道的大制片厂什么的，他们说，听着汤姆，我们想要一部历史史诗，但
subject of your choice and since you've done a lot to do with the second world war i'm going to ban you masters of the air presumably is that what i was about to say i'm going to ban you from a second world war or world war theme choice so you have to go back a bit further in history all right i'm good what are you gonna choose all right are you ready for this yeah maybe maybe like yourselves i know a number of people men and women of all of all ages some of them are peers and some of them are not whose lives were completely changed for the better over a long difficult struggle by are you ready for this? Yeah. Alcoholics Anonymous.
你可以选择任何主题，但既然你已经做了很多关于二战的内容，我要禁止你选择二战或与世界大战相关的主题，所以你必须往历史更久远的地方选。好吧，没问题。你要选什么？好吧，准备好了吗？是的，也许像你们一样，我认识一些人，无论男女老少，有些是我的同龄人，有些不是，他们的生活在经历了一场漫长而艰难的斗争后，因为——准备好了吗？是的。匿名戒酒互助会（Alcoholics Anonymous）。
Oh, wow. These guys came up with this thing called a 12-step program that just keep each other from drinking themselves into an alcoholic stupor. And that was in the 1930s, 1940s, and it really came about in the 1950s. Now, no one makes money off of my understanding of Alcoholics Anonymous, but if you were going to say, has there been a life-altering movement that has really changed, in some ways, the world for the better by way of defining and enlightening people in the realm of human behavior? I'd say Alcoholics Anonymous has, and I think it's a
哦，哇。这些人想出了一个所谓的“十二步疗法”，只是为了防止彼此喝到酒精中毒的地步。那是在20世纪30年代、40年代，真正兴起是在50年代。现在，没有人能从我对匿名戒酒互助会的理解中获利，但如果你要问，是否有一场改变生活的运动，通过定义和启发人类行为领域，在某种程度上让世界变得更美好？我会说匿名戒酒互助会做到了，而且我认为这是一个
fascinating story that has... I haven't read a lot about it, but there's a number of things like the history of that organization. It's about as vibrant and as vivid as any that you're going to come across. And the funny thing is that there are how many millions of members of Alcoholics Anonymous are there out there? And the most you can get out of any of this, well, how does it work? And they'll all say, well, quite nicely. Thank you. That's all you're going to get. That would be something that if someone wanted to throw down and say, let's examine that. Right.
引人入胜的故事……我没有读过太多关于它的资料，但关于该组织的历史有很多事情。它和你所能遇到的任何历史一样充满活力和生动。有趣的是，匿名戒酒互助会有多少百万会员？而你能从中得到的最多信息就是，嗯，它是如何运作的？他们都会说，嗯，效果很好。谢谢。这就是你能得到的全部信息。如果有人想提出来说，让我们研究一下，那会是一件很有意思的事。没错。
You heard it here first. Well, let's say they're listening. Yeah, of course they're listening. So I would be remiss. I would be letting myself down and my family down if i didn't ask you one last question and it is this is there any chance that you might put on the hat once more and bring woody back to the screens in another toy story film now everybody loves toy story except one person would you believe who that person is with us right now tom john holland he is tom holland can you believe
你在这里先听到了。好吧，假设他们在听。是的，当然他们在听。所以如果我不问你最后一个问题，我就失职了，我会让自己和家人失望的，那就是：你有没有可能再次戴上那顶帽子，在另一部《玩具总动员》电影中让伍迪重回银幕？现在每个人都喜欢《玩具总动员》，除了一个人，你敢相信那个人现在和我们在一起吗？汤姆·约翰·霍兰德，他就是汤姆·赫兰德，你能相信吗？
it's so shocking anyway let's put that we were very much as i think i've mentioned very much a forest gump family rather than a toy story family unbelievable i just wanted to put that on record i just wanted to shame tom but also would you play woody again Please say yes. This is in the hands of the great overlords of commerce. Absolutely. Matter of fact, I will tell you this. Tim Allen and I still get together about once a month because we knew that we were part of something quite profound that started 20, more than 25 years ago. That's when we did the first Toy Story. And there has been some jungle drums that, why not do it? Why not try to do it a fifth time? But I will say, I think the gatekeepers of all things, Woody and Buzz and Bo Peep and Slinky Dog and whatnot,
太令人震惊了。总之，让我们把这个放在一边，我想我提到过，我们家更倾向于《阿甘正传》而不是《玩具总动员》，难以置信。我只是想记录在案，我只是想羞辱一下汤姆，但你还会再演伍迪吗？请说愿意。这掌握在伟大的商业巨头手中。当然。事实上，我告诉你，蒂姆·艾伦和我每个月还会聚一次，因为我们知道我们参与了一件非常深刻的事情，始于20多年前，超过25年前。那是我们制作第一部《玩具总动员》的时候。有一些传言说，为什么不呢？为什么不尝试拍第五部呢？但我得说，我认为伍迪、巴斯、牧羊女、弹簧狗等等一切事物的守门人，
do not take their tasks lightly. No one is going to just rush something out. Quite right. If they do it, if it happens, boy, it's going to have to go through a hothouse atmosphere and pass all sorts of very, very rigorous sort of tests
对待他们的任务并不掉以轻心。没有人会匆忙推出什么东西。说得对。如果他们真的做了，如果这事发生了，天哪，它必须经过一个高压环境，并通过各种非常、非常严格的测试
before we would do that. But I'm game. I'd love to. Great news. I hope my voice is still high-pitched enough in order to get there. Buzz Aldrin, was he thrilled? Oh, God, yes. Oh, I'm to get there. Buzz Aldrin. Was he thrilled? Oh God. Yes.
我们才会这样做。但我愿意。我很乐意。好消息。我希望我的声音还能保持足够高的音调来完成它。巴兹·奥尔德林，他很激动吗？哦，天哪，是的。哦，我……来完成它。巴兹·奥尔德林。他很激动吗？哦，天哪。是的。
Oh, I'm sure he was. Buzz came to, I think every premiere there was for any of the toy story. I love it. Brilliant. Brilliant. Well,
哦，我相信他一定很激动。巴兹参加了每一部《玩具总动员》的首映式。我喜欢这个。太棒了。太棒了。好吧，
Todd, thank you so much for, for, for doing that. It's been absolutely wonderful. And, um, it would be remiss of me at this point,
托德，非常感谢你做这些。这绝对太棒了。而且，嗯，在这一点上，如果我不提，我就失职了，
not to mention the brilliant show, which you narrate moonwalkers, which is on at the Lightroom in London, King's Cross, until the 13th of October, 2024. Exactly right. And you tell the whole astonishing story, actually not just of people walking on the moon, but of humanity's obsession with the moon. It's wonderfully done. So thank you so much for joining us. Yeah, thank you very much, Tom. You're quite welcome. I will tell you this,
你担任旁白的精彩展览《月球漫步者》（The Moonwalkers），它在伦敦国王十字区的Lightroom展出，直到2024年10月13日。完全正确。你讲述了整个令人惊叹的故事，实际上不仅是关于人类登月，还有人类对月球的痴迷。做得非常出色。所以非常感谢你加入我们。是的，非常感谢你，汤姆。不客气。我告诉你，
this is just a warning to perhaps to some of your audience members. I was just in London and I jumped in a cab to get out to King's Cross. It was fabulous seeing a London black cabbie. I hopped in. I said, I'm going to a place called Lightroom. Do you know it? It's out in King's Cross. Well, I know
这只是给你们的一些听众提个醒。我刚在伦敦，我跳上一辆出租车去国王十字区。见到一位伦敦黑出租车司机真是太棒了。我跳了进去。我说，我要去一个叫Lightroom的地方。你知道吗？它在国王十字区。嗯，我知道
King's Cross is. That's what he said. So we we're on our way and he said where are you from and i said i'm from los angeles oh they're on australia but i can't quite understand but he says so why are you going to king's cross i said well i'm uh i'm going to this place called uh why is that i said well it's kind of like an exhibit kind of thing there's a there's a show there that we put on it and it's called the, the moonwalkers. Well, moonwalkers. Well,
国王十字区在哪里。他就是这么说的。所以我们在路上，他问我从哪里来，我说我来自洛杉矶。哦，他们是澳大利亚人，但我不太明白，但他问，那你为什么要去国王十字区？我说，嗯，我要去这个叫……为什么？我说，嗯，这有点像一个展览之类的东西，那里有一个我们举办的展览，它叫《月球漫步者》。嗯，《月球漫步者》。嗯，
is that Michael Jackson thing? I said, no, actually it's, it's not. It's about the, it's about the Apollo program that, Oh,
那是迈克尔·杰克逊的东西吗？我说，不，其实不是。它是关于……它是关于阿波罗计划的，哦，
it's Spaceman. Yeah. That was it. So, and in the words of that London cabin, it's not a Michael Jackson thing no it's not
是宇航员。是的。就是这样。所以，用那位伦敦出租车司机的话说，这不是迈克尔·杰克逊的东西，不，不是。
the Michael no it's not brilliant so on that bombshell thank you so much to Tom Hanks for
迈克尔，不，不是。太棒了。所以，带着这个重磅消息，非常感谢汤姆·汉克斯
joining us thank you to everybody for listening and I think Tom this experiment with Hollywood stars
加入我们。感谢大家的收听，我想汤姆，这次好莱坞明星谈论历史主题的实验
talking about historical subjects has been an absolute triumph yeah it's worked hasn't it let's keep it up you know what's
绝对是一个巨大的成功。是的，它奏效了，不是吗？让我们继续保持。你知道什么是
sad about this this is what this is what we talk about down at the office all the time anyway, guys. This is just a Friday for me. I'm glad you were a part of it. Thank you. Well, listen, next time we will be back with the Franco-Prussian War, and we'll be doing that with Zendaya. So we'll see you next week. Bye-bye. Sign me up. Take care, guys. Bye-bye. Bye-bye. Sign me up. Take care, guys. Bye-bye. Bye-bye. Bye. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman.
可悲的吗？这就是我们办公室里一直在谈论的事情。总之，伙计们。这对我来说只是一个周五。我很高兴你们参与其中。谢谢。好吧，听着，下次我们将回来讨论普法战争，我们将和赞达亚一起做。所以我们下周见。再见。算我一个。保重，伙计们。再见。再见。算我一个。保重，伙计们。再见。再见。再见。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。
And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works we have just launched our members club if you want ad free listening bonus episodes
我们共同主持《剩下的就是娱乐》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这是你每周的娱乐新闻、评论和一点点演艺圈八卦的来源。在我们的问答环节中，我们揭开了娱乐业的幕布，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部，如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集
and early access to live tickets head to therestisentertainment.com There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
以及提前获得现场演出门票，请访问therestisentertainment.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。